let's talk about gpt4 and large language
models so the AR in part trained on
Wikipedia content yeah uh what are the
pros and cons of of these language
models what are your thoughts yeah so I
mean there's a lot of stuff going on
obviously the Technologies move very
quickly in the last six months and looks
poised to do so for some time to come
um so first things first I mean part of
our philosophy is
the open licensing the free licensing
the idea that you know this is what
we're here for we we are a volunteer
community and we write this
encyclopedia we give it to the world to
do what you like with you can modify it
pre-distribute it pre-distribute
modified versions commercially
non-commercially this is this is the
licensing so in that sense of course
it's completely fine now we do worry a
bit about attribution because it is a
Creative Commons attribution sharealike
license so attributes is important not
just because of our licensing model and
things like that but it's just
proper attribution is just good
intellectual practice and so and that's
a really hard complicated question
um you know if
if I
were to write something about my visit
here I might say in a blog post you know
I was in uh
Austin which is a city in Texas I'm not
going to put a source for Austin as a
city in Texas that's just general
knowledge I learned it somewhere I can't
tell you where so you don't have to cite
and reference every single thing but you
know if I actually did research and I
used something very heavily it's just
proper morally proper to give your
sources so we would like to see that and
obviously
um you know they call it grounding so
particularly people at Google are really
keen on
figuring out grounding aesthetical terms
so ground any any text that's generated
trying to ground it to the Wikipedia
quality source source I mean like the
same kind of standard of what a source
means that Wikipedia uses the same kind
of generating yeah the same kind of
thing and of course one of the biggest
flaws in chargept right now
um is that it just literally will make
things up just to be
like amiable I think it's programmed to
be very helpful and amiable and it
doesn't really know or care about the
truth and get bullied into uh yeah it
can kind of be convincing too well but
like this morning I I was I the story I
was telling earlier about uh comparing a
football player to a Lamborghini and I
thought is that really racial I don't
know I'm just I'm mulling it over and I
thought I'm gonna go to church BT so I
sent to church gbt4 I said uh you know
this this happened in Wikipedia can you
think of examples where a white athlete
has been compared to uh
a fast car inanimate object and it comes
back as a very plausible essay where it
tells you know why these analogies are
common in support level I said no no I
really uh could you give me some
specific examples so it gives me three
specific examples very plausible correct
names of athletes and contemporaries and
all of that could have been true Google
every single quote none of them existed
and so I'm like well that's really not
good like I I wanted to explore a
thought process I was in and I thought I
thought first I thought how do I Google
and say well it's kind of a hard thing
to Google Because unless somebody's
written about this specific topic it's
you know oh it's large language model it
can it's processed all this data it can
probably piece that together but it just
can't yet so I think
uh I hope that
GPT five six seven you know three to
five years I'm hoping we'll see a much
higher you know level of accuracy
um where when you ask a question like
that I think instead of being quite so
eager to please by giving you a
plausible sounding answer it's just like
don't know or maybe uh display
the how much might be in this
uh generated text like yeah I'm really
would like to make you happy right now
but I'm really stretched in with this
General well it's it's one of the things
I I've said for a long time so in
Wikipedia one of the great things we do
may not be great for our reputation
except in a deeper sense for the long
term I think it is but you know we'll
we'll be a notice that says the
neutrality of this section has been
disputed or the following section
doesn't cite in these sources
um and I always joke uh you know
sometimes I wish the New York Times
would run a a banner saying the
neutrality of this has been disputed
they could give us we had a big fight in
The Newsroom as to whether to run this
or not
but we thought it's important enough to
bring it to you but just be aware that
not all the journalists are on board
with Ah that's actually interesting and
that's fine I would trust them more for
that level of transparency so yeah
similarly Chad GPT should say yeah 87
um well the neutrality one is
really interesting because uh that's
basically a summary
of the discussions that are going on
underneath it would be amazing if uh
like I should be honest I don't look at
the talk page often I don't it would be
nice somehow if there was a kind of a
summary in the in this Banner way of
like
this lots of Wars have been fought on
this here land for this here paragraph
It's really interesting yeah I hadn't
thought of that because we one of the
things I do spend a lot of time thinking
about these days and you know people
have found it we're moving slowly but
you know we are moving thinking about
okay these tools exist are there ways
that this stuff can be useful to our
community because a part of it is we we
do approach things in a non-commercial
way in a really deep sense it's like
it's it's been great that Wikipedia has
become very popular but really we're
just we're a community whose Hobbies
writing an encyclopedia that's first and
if it's popular great if it's not okay
we might have trouble paying for more
servers but it'll be fine and so how do
we help the community use these tools
what are the ways that these tools can
support people and one example I never
thought about I'm gonna start playing
with it is you know feed in the article
and feed in the talk page and say can
you suggest some warnings in the article
based on the conversation to the blog
page I think it might might be good at
that it might get it wrong sometimes but
again if it's reasonably successful at
doing that and you can say oh actually
yeah it does suggest
um you know the neutrality of this has
been disputed on a section that has a
seven page discussion in the back that
might be useful I don't know what you're
playing with I mean some more color to
the
not neutrality but also
the amount of emotion Laden in the
exploration of this particular part of
the topic yeah it might it might
actually help you look at more
controversial Pages uh like on you know
a page on the war in Ukraine or a page
on Israel and Palestine there could be
parts that everyone agrees on and
there's parts that are just like tough
tough the hard part it would be nice to
when looking at those beautiful long
articles to know like all right let me
just take in some stuff where everybody
agrees on I give an example that I
haven't looked at in a long time but I
was really pleased with what I saw at
the time so the the discussion was that
they're building something in Israel
and for their own political reasons uh
one side calls it a wall hearkening back
to Berlin Wall apartheid the other calls
it a security fence so we can understand
quite quickly if we give it a moment's
thought like okay I understand why
people would have
this this grappling over the language
like okay you want to highlight the
negative aspects of this and you want to
highlight the positive aspects so you're
going to try and choose a different name
and so there was this really fantastic
Wikipedia discussion on The Talk page
how do we word that paragraph to talk
about the different naming it's called
This by Israel is called this by
Palestinians and that how you explain
that to people could be quite charged
right you could easily explain oh
there's this difference and it's because
this side's good and this side's bad and
that's why there's a difference or you
could say actually let's just let's try
and really stay as neutral as we can and
try to explain the reasons so you may
come away from it with with a concept uh
oh okay I understand what this debate is
about now and uh just the term Israel
Palestine conflict hmm is still the
title of a page at Wikipedia But the
word conflict is something that is a
charged word of course yeah because uh
from the Palestinian side or from uh
certain sides the word conflict doesn't
accurately describe the situation
because if you see it as a genocide One
Way genocide is not a conflict because
to that to to people that uh discuss
that challenge the word conflict they
see you know conflict is when there's
two equally powerful sides fighting yeah
yeah no it's it's hard and you know in
in a number of cases so this is this
actually speaks to a slightly broader
phenomenon which is there are a number
of cases where there is no one word that
can get consensus and in the body of an
article that's usually okay because we
can explain the whole thing you can come
away with an understanding of why each
side wants to use a certain word but
there are some aspects like the
paychecks have a title
um so you know there's that same thing
with
um certain things like photos you know
it's like well there's different photos
which one's best a lot of different
views on that but at the end of the day
you need the lead photo because there's
one slot for a lead photo
categories is another one
um so at one point I have no idea if
it's in there today but I don't think so
um
I was listed in uh you know kind of
American entrepreneurs fine American
atheists and I said hmm that doesn't
feel right to me like just personally
it's true I mean I wouldn't wouldn't
disagree with the objective fact of it
but when you click the category and you
see sort of a lot of people who are you
might say American atheist activist
because that's their big issue so
Madeline Murray O'Hare or various famous
people who uh Richard Dawkins who make
it a big part of their public argument
and persona but that's not true of me
it's just like my private personal
belief it doesn't really it's not
something I campaign about so it felt
weird to put me in the category but like
what category would you put you know and
and do you need that guy in this case I
was I argued it doesn't need that kind
of like that's not I don't speak about
it publicly except incidentally from
time to time I don't campaign about it
so it's weird to put me with this group
of people and that argument here today I
hope not just because it was me but
um but categories can be like that where
you know you're either in the category
or you're not and sometimes it's a lot
more complicated than that and is it
again we go back to is it undue wait uh
you know if
uh someone who is now prominent in
public life and generally considered to
be a good person uh
was convicted of something let's say DUI
when they were young we normally in
normal sort of discourse we don't think
oh this person should be in the category
of American criminals because you think
a criminal technically speaking it's
against the law to drive under the
influence of alcohol and you were
arrested and you
spent a month in prison or whatever but
it's odd to say that's a criminal so it
just says like example in this area is
um
Mark Wahlberg Marky Mark that's what I
always think of a mask because that was
his first sort of famous name who I
wouldn't think should be listed as in
the category American criminal even
though he did he was convicted of uh
quite a bad crime when he was a young
person but we don't think of him as a
criminal should the entry talk about
that yeah it's actually that's actually
an important part of his life story you
know that he had a very rough use and he
could have you know gone down a really
dark path and he turned his life around
that's actually interesting so
categories are tricky
especially with people
because we like to sign labels to people
into ideas somehow and those labels
stick yeah and there's certain words
that have a lot of power like criminal
um like political Left Right Center
um anarchist
objectivist
uh what other philosophies are there
Marxist communist Social Democrat
Democratic Socialist socialist
and like if you add that as a category
all of a sudden it's like oh boy
you're that guy now yeah and I don't
know if you want to be yeah there's some
definitely some really charged ones uh
like alt-right I think it's quite uh
quite complicated and tough I mean it's
not a completely meaningless label but
boy I think you really have to pause
before you actually put that label on
someone partly because now you're
putting them in a group of people some
of them are quite
you wouldn't want to be grouped with
so it's yeah